[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the social
justice warrior what are we calling it
you know the social justice league also
just this little multicultural group of
friends with different opinions that
wanna talk I want to get whoa it's never
talking about diversity and the SJW
movement we were on unpopular opinion on
reddit it's titled cinema cinema gender
diversity was better before the SJW
movie oh no I don't believe that the
movement has gone overboard and made it
too obnoxious to watch movies aliens was
a great film because it was well written
and the characters Ripley was treated
like anyone else Sarah Connor was
another excellent character because like
Ripley there was almost no well she's a
woman moments yeah
let's just name a few bunch Princess
Leia Buffy Dana Scully Clarice Starling
are all great characters every time you
have to say wow look she's a woman
you basically disenfranchised her with
her which is ironic it's almost more
condescending it is I think it's like a
consolation prize they should just show
up [ __ ] vagina and give it and put a
cigarette in its mouth and give it a gun
because that's what and it's lazy
writing too it's very lazy writing and
it's the biggest thing because I feel
like first and foremost all characters
should be real people it's just like
because if I don't if you're just
putting it there just to have the
character there just to say you check
the box like you're not you don't
actually give a [ __ ] you're just trying
to [ __ ] like check a box so that
everyone goes and they become almost
more one-dimensional because they can
have no weaknesses yeah they have to
only be strong yeah it's the same way
with both both both ways like if I see
like a male character that's just a
[ __ ] troffer something like that I
was a shitty carry Superman a lot of
people hate Superman for that reason
because yeah what is he gonna struggle
against you know like kryptonite
kryptonite's crazy but it never kills
him videos just give them the flu every
time what did you guys think about
Captain Marvel it was the height of I if
they had to plug in a lot of stuff but
like I thought it was an ia movie I
liked what the cats were in it yes yeah
at the very end when she's [ __ ]
everything up I was like wow she's like
super in there's no reason
take everything on like when it when
they were doing in games of like that
when it's like where is she
Oh phew galaxies over it's like us
because she's gonna solve the problem
infant Li if you notice in all Justice
League books and [ __ ] they basically
have to do that to Superman like there's
a side line Superman somehow to give
everyone else a reason to even be there
ya know so actually not that great
because they mentioned Sarah Connor in
the reddit post and recently Dark Fae
determined Terminator came out and they
read change it so that John Connor
wasn't the Savior like boiler really
sorry sorry boiler alert oh my god I'm
sorry maybe like month anyways I'm gonna
forget I don't care so so the big thing
is that like Sarah Connor was like
setting this up for this whole woman
thing cuz now there's a new girl that
like is being hunted down and then she
was like oh you probably just like the
Sarah Connor is like you're probably
carrying the next world Savior in your
belly that's the reason what it is
they're coming for your womb not you so
that the end is descended of being like
no I'm a woman and I can be the savior
kind of a thing and then you had Sarah
Connor in that same franchise in the
first one that never really got brought
up or in the second one it wasn't like
I'm a woman and I am a badass
I'm kind of similar and then you just
mentioned early another video about like
the black the black is beautiful
movement I actually never really fully
was on board with that because it made
it seem like you had to reinforce that
like as if that wasn't already true kind
of a thing like I gotta be like uh like
it's beautiful but really should just be
like that should just be unknown already
not like a we have to reinforce that in
the same way that's saying dude there's
this scene so like have you guys seen
blue assassins you know that Netflix
yeah so it's a lot I forgot where it's
at but it but there's this scene where
they're like in a [ __ ] country ass
like diner and then like these guys are
eating and then they basically have to
tell this like lady off about Asian
history and how we're so American and
stuff and then the whole thing is
supposed to be like these guys are
badass but to me I see it as a table of
guys kind of being mean to a lady and
then you go and then the lady goes back
and in a bunch of like these white
hunter guys come and then they confront
the the table of Asian dudes and then
the Asian dudes come out and beat the
[ __ ] out
all the guys and in though I know
there's a lot of people that love that
scene but to me I'm like man we look
like a bunch of [ __ ] bullies there's
just a lot of shitty themes like that
that's coming out because you know it's
like whoa culture right it's like
there's this whole thing in Hollywood
where there's a conspiracy that they've
been trying to emasculate Asian men
right so I never [ __ ] fed into this
[ __ ] and I don't believe it William Hung
dude made it but then I got into this
[ __ ] argument one time because this
kid was right he wasn't a kid but he
wrote
yeah like Hollywood's gotta step it up
and put more like masculine Asian roles
because a lot of girls think I'm ugly
and this and that and I wrote back it's
not up to the MU industry to make you
feel like not like a little [ __ ] right
yeah it's like you make yourself feel
like a little [ __ ] it's not these
movies yeah
you're ugly those girls know what they
want it's not like they watch movie
stars and go like oh [ __ ] I wanna I'm
not gonna you know like I blame it on
the movies instead of taking
responsibility and changing their hey
Hollywood stop brainwashing them that
way brainwash them my way yeah that's
basically what they're saying you know I
can't get [ __ ] [ __ ] because Hollywood
always has white and black guys and no
asian guys as [ __ ] stars so there's
some I don't want to say truth but
there's some merit to what they're
saying but how much they make that
responsible like they're like oh my god
like I can't get laid or I can't get a
girlfriend because of that reason that's
a [ __ ] stretch man and that to me is
like the cop out yeah and what's weird
is that back in the day if anyone
[ __ ] amidst that [ __ ] or says it out
loud it's embarrassing but this
generation they say that [ __ ] out loud
and they're not embarrassed of it and
I'm the bad guy for calling them a
little [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so now I'll
get it you're not your good guy antihero
to me it's like grasping for their thing
to hang on to to identify and be like
victimized for but I don't like how you
can't dislike a movie and just dislike a
movie like if it's an all-women cast
it's like well you hate women in the
movement then and you're a backstabber
yeah
I don't like Ghostbusters you didn't
like bridesmaids I did like price great
different does it I was into oceans
eight I like the oceans eight although I
didn't like it I liked it and now
because it's a bunch of women just cuz I
thought it was a pretty neat like -
movie I didn't like crazier Jason's
about sucked
that's fine I liked hustlers and no one
liked it I liked husband's was good I
was surprised I had a jailer go to jail
away yeah what causes wound hustles to
what I'm talking on the hospital I don't
know I wanted to see that look good the
trail could but I didn't see you but you
hear about you do you anyone see the
surrounding press around Charlie's
Angels that just came out recently big
all guys now boiler alert it didn't do
well and but yeah it still it still
mostly female cast and stuff and then
Elizabeth Banks you I think produce to
you director if you directed yes you
know would have been real woke is three
gay guys a little bit very well or like
one transgender and two gay guys instead
three women you have been way more woke
as if Charlie was also a girl I thought
that was gonna happen at one point so
what happened right woman Elizabeth
Banks basically came out in response to
the poor box office results and she was
just like yeah I think it's just the the
market doesn't want to see like a movie
like there's like weird the overlap
between like guys like comic books and
stuff like they're just now it's so much
bulls they're just not gonna watch it
cuz it's a bunch of women in this movie
and then everyone I love watching a
bunch of women I remember the Charlie's
Angels movie that came out in a three
hundred nine ten years ago they made a
sequel cuz they made so much money it
was it Charlie things were full throttle
like taking responsibility or even a job
but then people pointed out [ __ ]
Captain Marvel did [ __ ] great at the
box office like banks is saying that
guys watched Wonder Woman's because it's
connected to the wreck shoes sued the
others yeah it's just like but that's
not why it just could be you could just
made a bad movie man like it's just like
why don't you just word of mouth was so
good on Wonder Woman it was unavoidable
to watch greater was dough when I watch
Wonder Woman it was a cute movie the
only thing that really threw me off was
the pacing of everything right yeah like
I didn't
way to hate women good job you know
what's up with that like you have to
blindly back up your tribe win crazy
which ages came out if you're Asian and
you didn't love it so I gave a standing
ovation dude oh great I love crazy
I enjoyed crazy rotation but I also
wouldn't elevate crazy rich Asians to
the level of like [ __ ] Shakespeare or
anything else no no not that I but 95%
swear to God the articles that I was
reading about I was like do you watch
the same movie like it's a great rom-com
I loved rom-coms by the way it's a solid
proposal like [ __ ] well you can have
that opinion
enjoy the movie as a whole so but I
don't think that just because it has a
bunch of Asians in it I needed to love
it I happen to like it I don't think
that it's anything more than what it is
though but I do think it's an important
movie like it definitely needed to be
proven that you know a bunch of Asians
could carry a rom-com movie you know and
that's fine the way it is just don't
make it more than it is
I will admit though I did like Black
Panther because I'm black okay fully
admit that I couldn't more deeply
because of especially the kill monger
african-american Bursley African like
you know dichotomy that was going on
like that was specifically like oh let's
talk to Antoine right now and like I was
like cool movie yeah Kennedy but what
don't you agree though kill muggers
character was way more [ __ ]
interesting yeah no for sure the main
character other Marvel villains or in
the movie no Panther was boring prepared
to kill me oh you know I grew that he
was so much more of an interesting
character because of this conflict as a
human being as a real person that you
can attach to the motivations where do
you think that the acting in crazy
Richard ah enjoyed it yeah that's fine
for rom-com like it wasn't again it
wasn't like a like Shakespeare but like
it was it goes good I think that I liked
Wonder Woman a little bit more because
you're willing not even just just being
a woman that to like because I used to
watch those movies and then have to be a
guy character if I wanted to be like the
badass character but also because she
kind of looked like more like me then
like a lot of the other heroine female
all girls like
oh not blind break hey ever see someone
that looked like me growing up like
watching those those shows and like you
know anything badass like I really
didn't see someone that looked like like
similar to me I think having that
representation like that was the first
time for me where actually saw it where
I was like I walked out of the movie
like oh my god how could you know like
yeah I hear that too I think that we
should have the representation there but
it shouldn't be yeah is the guy
acknowledging how [ __ ] Asian he is no
I hate that [ __ ] I want there to be a
big future and never once anyone ever
benches legs again yeah do you want to
mean like there was much was it up
patting it with murder actually
ParaNorman though at the ending of
ParaNorman the one of the main like buff
like character kid that by ever that the
girl that the girl is like swooning over
and stuff he's like oh no I got a
boyfriend or whatever and it's just like
the whole movie or throwing away a gal
know that he's gay at the moment where
he's sucking a dick right right not
before that point who cares
he should be stuck in the neck and then
he should be like oh by the way I'm gay
Yeah right
the reason like the fire fest
documentary you know know what this -
this definitely is the Hulu and it was
the one where he was like I was prepared
to suck his dick like I don't think
anyone knew that he was gay the manager
oh the main guy Andy Andy yeah oh that's
right because you did say that at one
point when he was trying to coordinate
he was like I would have done that to
make this work props to that dude by the
way [ __ ] you what the extra mile I
don't really mind the gay parading you
know that or like the asian-ness or the
blackness or whatever I think it has to
call for that right so if the movies
about about race relations and it makes
[ __ ] sense but like if it's a Marvel
movie and you need a guy every [ __ ]
line to mention how asian he is or
whatever I hope that God shang-chi is
not like that that just gets annoying as
[ __ ] because it's it's so [ __ ]
unintelligent it's like a low common
demand the way that it's it's catering
to [ __ ] dog box and when I watch
those movies I'm like stop insulting me
yeah
because again yeah like Umbrella Academy
there was like the Asian duty you never
like there's none of them refer to their
yes and he doesn't turn off the shoes
and run in the [ __ ] house and she
doesn't have to be a ninja just because
of the Asian one it never says what is
it cuz I'm Asian or anything god you
have like a gay guy a black girl like
they have everything but they're not
that's not that's never invention is not
based on that and as a straight white
man that's my worst nightmare
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]